Cortana.
There, Mike.
How are you?
Doing very well, Mike. Can you hear me okay? Because I'm in a conference room, so I don't know if you're able to hear me okay.
I think I can hear you, buddy.
That's fine then. And then I don't have to plug the LAN cable in because he's connected via Wi-Fi. That's great.
Ha ha ha.
Alright, so how have you been?
Mike, can you hear me?
Mike, I'm not able to hear you if you're saying something.
Sometimes it's hard for Mike to figure out how to use computers.
Hey, Natalie, can you hear me?
Noah, is it? Yeah, I can hear you now. Is it? Was it Noah?
Yeah.
Yeah, this is Noah.
Are you like sitting together?
It's my headphones.
No, no, no, no, no, no, I mean, unless he's at my house, but in that case, that that's deuce to me.
Ohh.
Now I can see Brian, Noah. Thank you guys for joining in. Appreciate it. Hey, Brian, how are you?
Good, Kevin. How are you, bud?
I'm doing very well, thank you. It seems like there's a lag. I don't know why.
Good.
Did you feel like there's a lot?
Might be a little lag.
Well, you are on the other side of the earth.
I've been having my...
Mm.
Well, yeah. And I've been having issues with my internet for the past couple of days, so it might be me personally if nobody else sees it.
Okay.
Yeah, let's do one thing. If it gets bad, just let me know. I'll just go to my workstation and I'll just take the call from there.
Just gonna actually, I'm gonna turn my camera off.
Ha ha ha.
But laugh, and I'm the only one who's like, you know, with the camera on.
Ohh.
I'm just trying to clear up some bandwidth here.
Yeah.
But look, you do have the best beard, so...
So, you know what? Brian is frozen.
It's probably like your cameras be on.
Brian is through, okay, there you go, he just...
Okay.
He was frozen, and Brian.
I'm so sorry to share this with the entire group, but I got a beautiful picture of yours, so I'm gonna just share it with everyone, but this is how Brian Brian looks when when the screen got frozen.
Ha ha ha!
Uh-oh.
But.
Okay.
We're gonna make a poster of that.
I like that.
Oh, we're we're hanging in in the office.
Yeah, big old.
Pouchin.
Touch.
My hair is all disheveled.
Yeah.
Ha ha ha!
But.
Hey, Brian, I think I think it's time for you to say bye to the hair.
That's hurtful.
Hey, I still got plenty up there. Don't be jealous, buddy.
Look, you have plenty, but it's slowly moving backwards.
Hey.
I mean, honestly, you could rock the mullet.
I probably could.
OK, cool.
Alright, let's get this shindig on the road.
Perfect, so let me share my screen, OK, and...
That's.
I know when you can see my screen now because I'm just using my laptop with one screen. It's very hard for me to.
Both.
Where's the screen? Okay, I think I got it now. Okay, let's see. You should be able to see it now.
Yes.
Yep, Ashish.
Oh, that's cool. All right, gentlemen, welcome to our monthly business check-in for TTG. We will be looking at, you know what, you'll be looking at April month's data. I've just mentioned May, but we were looking at last month's information. So moving on with the agenda items, it stays pretty much the same. We'll go through the highlights.
Ben.
Performance analysis, ITBD C set, US holiday schedule, Team GPS way forward, then meeting minutes. Highlights, Mandy is now AZ 104 certified.
Ohh.
It's a big deal for Mandy. He completed his certification.
Yay!
Wow.
He is, he also completed his CompTIA plus training, which I think we already, I think we did discuss last time. I'm not 100% sure, but he was able to complete CompTIA plus training. Apart from this, on-call is going strong, no complaints. So he's settled in and I think he's enjoying on-call now.
Mhm.
Okay.
Rest, thank you guys for supporting Mandy. He is.
He has never said anything which where I have to reach out to you guys. So that's a huge thing. You know, kudos to you guys for keeping him happy. And trust me, I don't have to do anything because the support that he's getting from you is just phenomenal. So thank you so much for that.
Yeah, he's great. So I'm glad he feels supported. That's good.
Okay.
And.
Awesome. Anything that you want to add before we get on the get on to the next one?
Nothing from my side. I'm glad that he's moving forward his education with the A plus and the AZ 104. That's definitely good to see and hear. I definitely see it all the time on LinkedIn. He'll post whatever he gets in the certification and stuff. So I'm happy to hear that.
Yeah, absolutely. And he's not starving. He's going for another certification and you'll get the good news very soon. So just wait and watch. Okay.
Awesome!
That's awesome.
I am ready for it. I am ready to just watch them skyrocket.
He's setting the bar very high now, so it's difficult for, you know, us to reach that level. I mean, he's just setting, you know, he's setting the bar for himself so high that every time he, you know, goes above, he's setting a new one.
So it's like...
Exactly.
All right, perfect. So moving on with this performance.
So his average available utilization between Jan and April was at 65%. April was a good month for Mandy. He was able to reach 70%, which is great. Office 65, 30%, end user support, 30%. Kobe user support was 35%, and then wandering.
SOC knock alerts were like at 5%. So that was the top service drivers for the month of April. His ticket closure rate was 98%, which is phenomenal. And over the past four months, he has been achieving on an average of 97%. I don't have any complaints.
As per his performance, he's a rock star for me. I wish I had more individuals like Mandy to make my job easy.
Understood.
So any questions anyone?
I have no question.
No, I think this is great.
Awesome.
We love that he makes everybody's, because he makes our life a lot easier as well. So it sounds like he's just a rock star.
Yeah.
Maybe, maybe as per, you know, AI, which is a huge deal, I think there could be a way by which we can clone him, right? You never know. Things are going crazy with AI, so you never know. Maybe we can clone Brian as well. So.
Thank you.
Ohh.
Yeah.
I think we need to clone your beard so we can all just have the Kevin beard.
Akshay.
See.
Ha ha ha!
Yes, I like it.
That's a good one.
That's a good one, yes. I would love to share my beard with everyone, especially with Brian.
Yeah.
Um...
Okay, cool.
So his CSAT, ITBD CSAT is great. Thank you, Noah, for filling that out. It's 100%. That's amazing.
Holiday schedule. So the upcoming holiday is on July 3rd. He did work on Memorial Day. He hasn't told me when he will take his comp off. So as soon as I hear back from him, I'll let you know.
Okay, awesome. If he wants, he can use it for July 3rd. I mean, all we really need to know is sufficient time forward so we can make sure we have coverage for that.
Kip.
Mhm.
Oh, that would be great. And I think for now, he hasn't put in any PTO request as well. He may pin a request, but as soon as I hear back from him, I'll share the details with you.
Okay, awesome.
All right, build it. So is Brian coming?
Brian or maybe Mike or Noah, I mean, are you guys registered already?
So, I'm heading to a conference in June already, out for Vegas, but yeah, I'm not sure about Brian and Noah.
Okay.
I have not.
Yeah, so...
Did Mike, did you send this over to Brad? You said you were going to send that over to Brad for you and me, actually.
But yeah, and I pulled back on mine. You let me follow up with him. I did, but I think it was during some of this craziness he's been going through.
No.
Right.
So, let me let me follow up on that one. That's why it's today.
Yeah, so I mean, you have the QR code on the screen for getting the registration done. We are also running a promo, which is BOGO. If you book one seat, you'll get the second one free of cost. So you can, you know, get that.
Yeah, we saw that.
Yep.
Uh, listen, I can't see it from my...
Andy, I think Andy already sent all that information over to me and I sent it to Mike.
That's great.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, so if you need any help.
Yeah, we'll get some answers here.
If you need any help, you can just let us know if you're facing any issues with the registration. I mean, you can send an email to Andy and myself and then we can look into it.
Okay.
Okay, but we would love to have you this year, so looking forward to it.
Moving on, AI by Design will be added to our Build It conference, so it will be an added value addition for CDG. So if you can make it, which I am 100% sure you will, this will be great for the entire group.
Ohh.
Okay, Team GPS, we have been discussing Team GPS. You have the again scan QR code on the screen. You can scan it for a demo and then we can talk about it. Way forward, as you all know, Mandy continues to kill it. My expectations from him is now even higher than before.
Be great.
So let's see if he's able to meet or maybe exceed our expectations. We'll see that. But overall, we just want to make sure that he continues to deliver exceptional service to TTG. And that is the way forward. With this, we come to the end of our presentation. I'm going to go around the table. So we'll start
Vaid.
No, IU for any questions, concerns, or feedback for us.
I have nothing on my side. I mean, you know how I feel about Mandy. I just love the guy. So we're happy to have him part of the team, happy that he feels supported and that he has no concerns or anything. Yeah, we're of course always happy with Mandy.
Yep. Thank you. Thank you, Noah, for your feedback. Truly appreciate it. And now it's Mike, your turn.
Yeah, no, I think I think he's doing a great job. The guys seem to work really well with him. He seems eager to learn more and to stay ahead of things. What I would also do for next meeting is include Kris. Kris is now kind of his pseudo
A mentor, we haven't made a manager kind of yet with some kind of working on the structure, but Kris has been running that service that's going to get to work closely with Mandy every day. So I think he'd appreciate, you know, hearing.
Mhm.
Okay.
presentation that you do monthly, and then also he might have a little bit closer feedback, which I'm sure is positive, but might give you a little more insight than what I can give you.
So, I'll get you his email address if you don't have it already.
Okay.
That would be great. So currently, is he reporting to Noah or is he reporting to Kris?
So technical on paper, it's me. Noah was driving the service desk for a while, but Noah now has been taking over a lot of our internal and external projects, onboarding, things like that. And so Kris has been working closely with Connor and Mandy on a daily basis to help grow them. So he's going to have more of that nitty-gritty information.
Mhm.
Okay.
OK.
That I don't have.
So yeah, thank you, Mike, for sharing. So what I'm hearing is that going forward, Kris will be the one who will be managing Mandy, right?
Yeah, day in and day out. Yep. Yeah, it's kind of a dotted line right now. We're gonna go ahead.
Just on.
Yeah, just on the daily, like day-to-day type stuff, you know, questions asked on the Helpdesk, that kind of stuff. Chris is, Chris is kind of leading that, that joint, that venture.
Yeah.
Mm.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, but I'm a little confused over here. So Kris will be managing Mandy on day to day, but he'll be reporting to Mike. Mike then, but I just need to know the reporting piece. Will it be Mike or Kris?
So Mike, Mike is in charge of our group as a whole.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
So he needs to, he is, he is your contact as far as the Helpdesk team. You know, obviously, I've been here along the way just to make sure everything is going good. I'm not really needed because I'm not really on the help desk anymore on the day-to-day activities, but I still enjoy coming here and hearing about
Team.
OK.
Mm.
Yep.
his successes and everything. So yeah, it's just adding, I mean, adding Kris to this. And then that way, if I'm not available, at least another pair of ears is here. But, you know, ultimately it is kind of Mike, Noah, Kris, then Mandy in a way.
Mhm.
Mm.
You know, Noah's just our lead on the help desk as a whole, but he is kind of doing more internal project work than anything else right now. So that's why we're kind of relying on Kris to handle the day-to-day help desk activities and being there to mentor and coach the team.
Popkin, cool.
Understood.
Okay.
Just to reconfirm.
And that's all I got to say about that.
Yep, yep, and just to reconfirm that from, so should I add Kris to our calls? I mean, I can send the UI to him. Okay, I'll do that. And Noah is not going anywhere, right? He'll be still using, he'll be still connecting on these calls, right?
Yes.
Yes, thank you.
Yes, please.
Correct.
Yeah, it's his option. He can be optional.
You can't get rid of me. You can't get rid of me. No, the big thing is, the big thing with Kris is that I was getting stretched very thin with all the projects where I wasn't able to provide the level of guidance and kind of management that was needed.
That, I just want to.
for a lot of the team, just because of all the projects are taking up a lot of time of mine. So Kris has kind of taken that over because he's able to provide the more proactive guidance that they need.
Hmm, understood. Yeah, no, I mean, overall, from my perspective, you know, we welcome this decision because end of the day, we just need to make sure that...
From CDG perspective, you are providing all the support to Mandy, and Mandy knows who to reach out to when he needs any help, right? So that structure should be strong so that tomorrow if he gets stuck, then he knows who to reach out to. So I think Kris will definitely be a huge help, and then obviously he can reach out to Mike, Noah.
Yes.
whoever he wants to, just to, you know, so that structure has to be clear. And maybe if there's any org chart around this, Brian, if you can just share that with me, that'll be great. So that tomorrow, if I need to reach out, I should be reaching out to maybe Mike or.
Correct.
So if you can share that, that'll be great. Otherwise, you know, that's okay.
If that's a, if that's a...
Let's say we could do it. I mean, you bring up a good point, right? I mean, from a contact perspective, I think Mandy knows who to go to. It is pretty clear. But yeah, that wouldn't be a bad idea to put some of it down on paper of the go-tos. So, you know, the tough thing is we're a small team. So we still talk a lot of internally and share. But as we do grow, that could be harder to sustain that.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay.
So, yeah, let me work on an org chart.
Mm.
Okay, perfect. That'll be awesome. Okay, Brest, I think I'm good. Brian, do you have anything else to add? Because now it's your turn.
The only question I have is with him, you know, passing all these certifications and everything, what, what is his, what's his goal as far as, you know, staying, staying with you, staying with us? Hopefully we can continue to
to put him and give him more of the tier 2, tier 3, is he satisfied with continuing that with us or does he look into like get to a certain point and then, you know, making a jump to a much higher level engineer than
Yeah.
what we necessarily need.
That's a great question, Brian. Looking at his growth, we just want to make sure that from our perspective, we are giving growth to all of our engineers, right, including Mandy. He will be due for his level up very soon. So I think all these certifications will help him.
Absolutely.
in his career when he's growing. So if you have that level 2, level 3 work, then I think he should be satisfied with the work that he'll be getting, right? I think if we hit a ceiling, we can only hit a ceiling when we don't have that work, right? So if engineers are growing, they are leveling up.
Yep.
up if you're able to provide the work, then I think we should be in a good place.
Right, but but that that's a great question.
I just want to make sure that he continues to, I know he says that he's happy, but I just want to make sure that for, at least for a
Mhm.
We'll say short-term one year if he's still, you know, willing to stick with us.
Mm.
Yeah. No, absolutely. And trust me, from my perspective, I want this relationship to even go beyond, you know, five years. But you know how things are. We just want to make sure that we go step by step, and then accordingly, we'll figure out things along our way.
Okay, very good.
Kam.
All right, rest, I'm good from my side. Thank you so much. Brian, just a small request. If you can just check with Brad for Mandy's on-call for the month of April, if you can just approve it, then we can, you know, credit him. I mean, as for the next payroll cycle.
I'm not sure if you've already approved it, but if you can just, you know, follow up, that would be great.
Yeah, one of us can prove that. It doesn't necessarily have to go to Brad.
That's.
Well, Brad pays it though. Brad pays the bill. Unless you have the ability.
Oh, you were saying he has a...
He hasn't paid yet, is that what you're saying? Understood.
Okay, well...
Probably, I have not seen that payment.
Okay, we'll side it with Debra.
Yeah, I approved the amount. I think right now it's just waiting for Brad to just pay it.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll follow up with him then. Will do.
Yep.
Mike, you gonna handle that then with with Brad?
Yeah, I'll reach out to Brad.
Okay.
Okay, perfect. Rest, I'm good, guys. It's a pleasure, as always, connecting with you, speaking with you. One day, personally, I'll also be there so that we can have a good time. We'll go to a bar. You know, you never know. Okay.
Haha.
Excellent, yeah, yeah.
We would all be happy to do the draft.
Like it.
All right, perfect. So on that note, thank you so much for that today. Thank you so much for joining. We'll speak to you next month. Till then, have a good one. Take care. Bye-bye.
Home.
So.
Alright, talk to you later, Kevin. Bye.
So, thank you, sir.
Thanks, Kobe. Take care, buddy.
Bye.